let us start with
the panel
in the panel
i am excited to see
dr um
gus casulis
so
dr casulis is the president of the
national association of idea principal
investigators
he received his degree in physics um
from the fairly dickinson university
in new jersey
and his master's degree and phd degree
from pennsylvania state university in
biophysics and molecular cell biology
he received post-doctoral training at
the university of chicago working in dr
bernard roizman's laboratory at the
university of california at san
francisco with dr lenoir pereira where
later he was promoted to research
assistant professor he joined louisiana
state university in baton rouge
louisiana in 1988 and became professor
in 1994.
he's currently professor of virology and
biotechnology at the lsu school of
veterinary medicine with adjunct
appointments at the department of
biological sciences biotechnology
college of basic sciences the department
of microbiology and immunology at the
lsu health sciences center in new
orleans and the lsu health sciences
center stanley s scott cancer center in
new orleans
he is also an affiliate member of the
tulane national primate research center
located in covington louisiana and he's
serving as the head of the department of
pathobiological sciences and is the
director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine at
lsu school of veterinary medicine he is
also the principal investigator of the
louisiana biomedical research network
funded by nih nagms and other extramural
and intramural sources
so
dr casulis welcome
hey hello everybody uh glad to be here
uh thank you elia i guess you're gonna
introduce all the other speakers before
we start the panel right
yes exactly thank you very much
our
second panelist is uh dr sona uh
vasudevan
uh so
dr sona vasudevan is the director of the
systems medicine
master's degree at georgetown university
her interests span in the areas of
structural biology structural
bioinformatics homology modeling protein
ligand and antibody antigen interactions
and rna biology her research interests
include comparative genomics protein
classification
protein homology modeling
and molecular dynamics simulations to
look at the effect of single nucleotide
polymorphisms in breast cancer as well
as evolutionary analysis systems biology
and translational informatics she has
contributed to the development of
several well-known bioinformatics tools
for doing sequence and structure
analysis she has developed a drug
discovery database and her research
record includes several research papers
invited lectures and book chapters
she serves on the editorial board of and
is a reviewer for several journals she
teaches biochemistry structural biology
and several courses in informatics and
she has mentor mentored many students
and created an mdms dual degree program
in systems medicine and a freestanding
ms degree program in systems medicine
and she has received numerous academic
awards and excellence in teaching awards
as well so welcome dr vasudevan
thank you iliacz my pleasure to be here
uh thank you for that wonderful
introduction
looking forward to the panel
okay great thank you very much
we also have here dr leonid brodsky
who is the outgoing
director of the tower bioinformatics
research center at the university of
haifa in israel so dr leonard brodsky
authored a long list of research
publications and his background is in
biostatistics mathematics and over the
past several decades he has been working
in bioinformatics
he has been leading bioinformatics
research computational biology and
systems biology modeling
for over 30 years
his work
is primarily in bioinformatics algorithm
development for many years and as a
result of that work he has produced a
number of new approaches to biomedical
data analysis and integration
so currently he is
working at the tower bioinformatics
research center and being the scientific
advisor to many
research projects with collaborators of
that center as well so welcome dr lena
brodsky
thank you very much
and also we have today
dr raul andino
dr raulandino
is a professor in the department of
microbiology and immunology at the
university of california san francisco
dr andino is a virologist and professor
in the department of microbiology and
immunology at the university of
california in san francisco he is noted
for leading a team of researchers that
developed the first new oral polio
vaccine in 50 years
he has been working in biology for over
30 years and has a broad background in
rna virus biology with focus on
molecular biology and biochemistry viral
immunology vaccine development and
evolutionary biology
rna viruses are a major threat to human
health and they also provide a
fascinating window into processes that
can be harnessed to improve human life
so welcome dr andina
thank you pleasure to be here
okay great to have you
and finally we have dr laura harris
so dr laura harris is a research mentor
and director of training at michigan
state university
dr harris is an educator who enjoys
developing curriculum that involves
involves use of computational resources
she also enjoys mentoring others in data
science and biomedical research her
projects use bioinformatics and basic
laboratory approaches to examine gene
expression changes
associated with antibiotic resistance in
bacterial species microbial induced
cancer and source cove too dr harris is
involved with the american society for
microbiology and has co-authored several
educational and scientific papers
welcome dr harris
thank you a pleasure to be here this
morning
all right great so after all of these
introductions again thank you everyone
for being here
essentially what we've done is we've
compiled several questions from all of
the participants of the symposium that
we hope that you can help us address and
so what i wanted to start is what are
some of the changing dynamics around
omics data so essentially what do you
see from your perspective how is this
field of omics data changing in terms of
data availability data quality
data access and i wanted to first ask
dr andino if you could kind of
share with us your thoughts on that
subject
yeah i mean um thanks ilya i i think
that
there's
obviously a very important um
important exercise that we need to do in
terms of integrating
the intuition that many of us have in
biology with the intuition that many
computational scientists have and so
the first thing that you really
need to think about it is how to
integrate
that kind of perspective and intuition
that only
comes
when a scientist is involved in this
type of work for for for years so you
know transmitting that kind of intuition
is is critical because
um it it
it really
um allows you to define the questions
and of course then they find the
technical approach to
uh access to
the information
and as you know elia because we've been
working for many years uh together one
of the things is fascinating to me is
that every biological uh process
from an enzyme recognizing the substrate
all the way to
epidemiological process um they are
dictated by um the dynamics of the
process
and i always put this example that if
you see a picture of a cat in the air
you really don't know whether the cat is
falling or jumping um and you really
need a movie
um you know a series of uh pictures that
capture the dynamics and then you will
know the cat is uh jumping from one
place to the other and so that the same
thing happened with with um biology
and i think
the the whole thing
jumps to i mean it boils to a simple
matter of
good data
perhaps temper with certain temporal
resolution
that allows to train
models
and that will
enable understanding those dynamics the
higher resolution the data is the better
the models will be
but i think the models play a very
important role in defining uh the type
of experiments that one can do
if one has the opportunity
to
obtain
data that will be more
useful to fit these models then um you
will be able to have this sort of
iterative
process in which the models
gets
better defined
based on the data and the data gets
better defined based on the models
thank you thank you very much for that
um good illustration with the cat so i
really like that you really don't know
what's going on unless you see it
um so so with that being said
my next question would be about what is
really the need for multiomics
integration with you know genomic
transcriptomic different types of omics
data
um you know what is the need to be able
to integrate them and and what are some
of the ways that it could be done and so
i wanted to ask that question from dr
leonid brodsky if you can kind of expand
on that
yes thank you
okay
first i believe
that actually we have
some difficulties with
many technologies in multi-omics data
and
the question of integration is how to
combine all these technologies which
they gave actually are giving different
results
and after that how to move from all of
that to biology
second i completely agree with raul that
a
time dimension is in integration is
extremely important because actually it
is
saying
what kind of
biology
we
virtually can expect
from
our experiment like like
cell
differentiation or
[Music]
processes with organisms like aging and
things like that
and of course
development of
virus infection
so
two major issues i believe
different how to combine different
technologies
and how to
stream all of that to time dimension
okay great thank you very much so
uh you know multiomics integration i
know that you've been working on that
for a long time but
essentially there's also where i will
mention this
kind of discussion with biologists maybe
is really critical and
i also wanted to ask
about the
ways that omix data is essentially
changing research projects and we
already kind of heard about basic
research but in terms of translational
research i know that uh dr vasudevan you
work with a lot of clinicians you're in
the medical school you kind of prepare
students for systems medicine
what is your take on how omiks data and
and some of the things that were
mentioned by dr dino and dr bronski how
how is that changing uh those research
projects that you see happening around
you
yeah thank you elia for that question i
was hoping you'll ask me that question
um and thanks to uh dr andino and dr
brotzky who already laid
amazing foundation in terms of
where we are in terms of starting any
research projects so the way i look at
things
and the changing phase of informatics is
that it's become a very
interdisciplinary field
so
we cannot just each i am a physicist by
training converted myself to a biologist
and an information
but with so much of data coming from all
over the place transcriptomics
proteomics are pretty much i think there
are like 238 or 40 different omic terms
and so much data out there
the biggest change um in
designing a research project is to have
an interdisciplinary team
so we need a clinician
we need a biologist
in fact we even need an economist now uh
to see um the different ways to do
things so the way uh even when i teach
medical students so we talk about one
disease one gene
so that's no longer in play right now uh
because it's like a whole systems
approach uh different uh genes
expressing different organ systems uh
different cell types
uh different things so it's a whole
systems approach so what is really
changing with all of this is of course
multi-omics integration is crucial
and the most important is also
interdisciplinary collaborations with
different
expertise that is involved and that's
what i teach the students and we have a
team now uh with different expertise and
and i'll be talking more about the
program at georgetown tomorrow but um
that's pretty much
how
we have designed so that there is a lot
of collaboration across different uh
fields
and that makes um multi-integration more
efficient as well
okay great thank you very much uh for
that insight
dr vasudevan and uh you know another
thing that i know that is a challenge in
some ways with this kind of dynamics of
onyx data is
essentially how is it practically used
so i know that there are hubs where you
know omix data is available
and everybody seems to know how to use
it and then there are places where
there's a need for
training there's a need for access and
there's a need for kind of elevating the
level of biomedical research and i know
that dr kusulus you're involved with
louisiana biomedical research network
with
the national association of idea
principal investigators and so i wanted
to ask you a question about how
important is bioinformatics in many of
the research projects that you and are
involved in as i'm sure a mentor and a
reviewer um for many of these networks
and and how do you see the trajectory of
kind of data science and bioinformatics
as a critical need in many of the
projects that you oversee
yeah thanks elia
elijah mentioned that nepi the national
association of idea principal
investigators just to give you a
very brief
description this is a nonprofit 503c
corporation that represents
23 states and puerto rico
the program is funded through nih with
over 400 million dollars per year in
multiple centers centers for biomedical
recess excellence that relates to
promoting people into independent
funding through the r1 mechanism
every state has the
inbree programs the national
idea
biomedical research excellence programs
uh to promote um
biomedical research and those inbree
programs for every state had a priority
for data science and bioinformatics and
of course we have the entrepreneurship
hubs and the clinical translational
centers
uh that these are the four programs that
are part of nappy there are over 170
programs and principal investigators
that are members of nepe representing
those 23 states in puerto rico and as
already alluded to
nih has recognized
the importance of data science and
bioinformatics in fact there is a
complete division of data science and uh
the
teaching and training and providing
support for data science by
bioinformatics is now mandatory for all
the embry programs for those 24 states
and of course it's extremely used
into the clinical translational centers
that are funded by near gms as well by
other categorical institutes and the
kobe programs the center for biomedical
research excellence
the nih recognition of this importance
is
really multi-level because
now they have arranged with
microsoft and amazon and others to
really utilize
their resources
to be able to really do high-level
computation in the cloud as opposed to
locally and of course there are
many many databases that are now
supported by nih for clinical
translational research um
the the goal of nappy as well all the
inbree other programs
are really to reach out
and prepare
uh faculty staff and students in dealing
with bioinformatics and of course as a i
was alluded to a couple of speakers i'm
also a physicist that turned into
molecular biologists
and
my view of the world is that really
everything that we look at in biology
which often is descriptive ultimately
has a physical explanation to it and it
defined parameter to it every process
that we do whether is receptor binding
or anything internal to the cell it's
actually described can be described by
some physical formula and ultimately uh
this physical world
uh really translates into
tremendous amount of information that
cannot really be handled uh through a
descriptive
uh
way of understanding what what's
happening
within
that cell
tissue or organism or even in population
as we would do that and that's where we
need the computational tools and the
approach that we use
is really not only to have uh
interdisciplinary teams which obviously
at the level of higher education is a as
a solution
but even more importantly to really
teach
uh young
students undergraduates graduates
the basic tools of data science and
bioinformatics through intensive
exercise programs because i think
ultimately we need
interdisciplinary education
at all levels um because uh
the new generations
need to be trained uh to understand and
utilize these tools and the quicker and
earlier we reach out to them the more
important
would be for them as they pursue
biomedical research
and of course this is extremely needed
uh i think 90 or more of every research
grant i reviewed
not only within the lbrm program but
international programs which cancer
research
or
infectious diseases now use advanced
transcetomics rna-seq proteomics
integration of transcriptomics
proteomics and genomics so it's a must
tool now it's a necessary tool to be
able to compete
at a higher level
okay thank you very much dr casulis and
um
my next question is
uh to dr harris who i know is somewhat
of a recent convert to the domain of
bioinformatics and also comes from a
biology background and now deals with a
lot of student projects as a mentor and
you know runs a whole program and so i
wanted to ask dr harris
what are some of the ways that
researchers and students can prepare to
deal with this increasing volume and
complexity of omics data in research you
know how did you yourself come to
the need for bioinformatics and how are
you using it now
great question um i came to need
bioinformatics mainly because i ran out
of options in a wet bench setting so wet
bench tends to be very expensive it can
be very time consuming and it generates
a limited amount of data for usually the
money that you're putting into an
experiment
by using things like computational
meta-analysis approach you can then take
different experiments across different
labs and then synthesize new information
that may be missed if you're just
looking at a couple of samples or a
couple of mice in your own lab
but that can be very overwhelming and it
was overwhelming for me when you see how
big some of these data sets can be when
you start aggregating them across
different platforms or
knowledge bases
so my advice to new students is really
be organized and i have come to find
myself falling back on the traditional
lab notebook
that i was trained with in the wet bench
so you know we're trained we have a lab
notebook we go into the lab we document
everything that is done that day
procedure results corrections thoughts
on tweaking the procedure that sort of
thing
the same thing applies to bioinformatics
so you have to treat it just like you
would a wet bench research project you
need to have a notebook that says you
know i tried this approach it worked it
didn't work why do i think it didn't
work what am i going to change next time
because when you start layering all
these different omics or for me
multi-omics on multi-projects it can be
very confusing and overwhelming and even
intimidating to see just the amount of
data and having that
notebook to kind of help you break down
okay here's where that project is here's
what we did here's why something needs
to be tweaked the way it is is helpful
for my sanity
helpful for my student sanity and it's
also nice to then have a global
perspective across projects so if one
project encounters a problem and i
forget about it but then three weeks
later another project comes into a
similar problem i can then go back
through the notebook and say oh wait a
second yeah i remember how we fixed that
here now why don't we try it on this new
project and hopefully you get lucky
great thank you yes i think that is very
useful to kind of keep track of
everything and uh you know that brings
me uh to my next question
and this is um a question that i wanted
to start uh with uh dr andrino
you know you've been doing virology for
you know 30 years as i've read you know
in your background it wasn't around
maybe back when you started but uh how
has the
you know types of data
and the ways that this data is being
used uh you know how has it changed in
recent years for you for the types of
research that you and your lab do
you're on mute
yes it's obvious that
the
process the data that we're using as a
little bit of what dr harris was saying
um you know it used to be
that uh you will run an experiment and
you will have a very
a specific um
answer to a particular process that is
well defined within your experimental
paradigm
and and this has changed enormously
because now
you are
able to
use um
a lot more data points and lot more
information from the same well-defined
experimental paradigm
and and the question is how you
interpret that and you know we've been
discussing about this you know this
ability to you know use this data to you
know try to extract more information to
this particular
um experiment
but i think what really is
transformative is what um
dr bassoden was saying at the beginning
what we're doing now is
and we do and we see this very clearly
on this process
what we are in the middle of this
pandemic
is that many of the things that we need
to do now
require the integration of different
experts
and i just wanted to say
that the olmics um
this is actually an interesting
um
interesting process because science is a
human activity
and one of the things that we
encountered recently is that the most
important thing you can do is to form a
team
that uh can create its own culture
so it can uh um sort of in
um interact in an effective way if you
need the expertise of a clinician um
biologist a computer scientist uh you
know an epidemiologist an economist
then you really need to have a common
language um and so in in my mind one of
the things that um is is changing now is
that uh we're starting to you know
generate some sort of culture of
discussion and this
symposium which i very excited to
participate precisely because you are
bringing
young people
that recognize
um the importance of this kind of omics
and integration
um but it's in in my mind is what gonna
be the
future scientists the scientists of the
future is where you you know really
create you you create a person that was
a scientist that is not afraid to reach
out
collaborate
and and um use all the information and
intuition that our experts have you know
developed over over years
and i'm not sure if i address the
question but
it to me is one of those uh you know
really important things that happened
to us in in recent years
so thank you yeah maybe not a direct
answer to the question but a very
meaningful kind of addition i think to
uh the need uh for interaction for the
need of uh common uh kind of
understanding and that ability to
listen to the different sides of the
story to really come up with results so
i think that was very useful so thank
you
for that
my next question is you know about the
necessary skills that you look for when
you are looking to add a
bioinformatician to join a project and
so i know that
you know in many areas bioinformatics is
such a
kind of a diverse term
it could mean something very simple it
could mean organizing a database it
could mean uh processing some data or
maybe developing a completely new
approach and an algorithm so it means
very different things in different kind
of fields so i do want to have all of
you uh you know kind of add to uh the
answers but my first question is to dr
bronson you know you lead a
bioinformatics research center you
develop novel algorithms and you kind of
identify solutions to problems that you
see biologists struggle with what are
some of the necessary skills that are
most important in your opinion for new
bioinformaticians or new people joining
your lab or your center
yes um
okay
actually
one cannot expect all kind of
expertise from a person
so it's better to have
several people with different
majors so to say
so i'm expecting
good programming skills and maybe high
level of programming
and algorithm development from some per
from
one type of people
another type of people
are
expertise
which have expertise in mathematics and
statistics this is
not always
the same the same person
is a good pro programmer and a good
mathematician
and actually
some basic knowledge of biology because
in biology we rely on our collaborators
not not on ourselves
and
so all together and the good contact
with collaborator
actually
this is what is needed for use for the
team
to
move
forward so thank you yes for that answer
um so i think uh kind of similar to what
uh dr andina also mentioned is that need
to
combine people from different
backgrounds and different skill sets and
enable them to work together and so in
the same
direction i also wanted to ask dr
kusulus
you know you
uh trying to work with these different
programs to not only train and build up
their capacity but eventually also to uh
kind of solve bioinformatics challenges
in a in a research project so what are
some of the things that you look for uh
when you're hiring uh you know
bioinformatician or when you're looking
to include a bound from addition in in
the research work that you do
yeah that's a very relevant question eli
thank you um obviously uh you know if
you're within uh certain institutions
you may not have the capacity to build a
team of three or four or more
bioinformaticians that represent
different aspects that are needed for
collaboration purposes
so the way we
recommend and we are using this is
really
to get only few people involved as
liaisons to um
resources and talent uh on the outside
uh so we look to hire a biopharmatician
that has
obviously computing strength some
statistics understands uh pipelines
we're using a lot through our illumina
based core bioinformatics for infectious
diseases rna-seq is the principle too
uh we're now going into metabolomics and
proteomics
data and the idea is to really have one
or two people we do have a phd for
instance in biostatistics we'll be
hiring a mathematician we had one we
lost them to the university of wisconsin
um but the idea is to really liaison
with resources and collaborators on the
outside so we have an mou with october
bioinformatics with center in israel
with dr brodsky
for potential collaborative projects and
of course we we work with fine biotech
to utilize their training
tools and pipelines
so
our accommodation is really for high-end
core facilities i like ours
that have supported a number of nih
projects
to have
two or three people internally that are
broadly educated and then link up to
external resources including really
commercial resources that are available
um
you know for a fifo service to provide
support for that but even beyond that i
think is extremely important what i
mentioned earlier
we like to
push
the ability to handle data
at the lowest possible level so
intensive training of graduate students
you know undergraduate students that are
in computer science that want to learn
biology biologists that want to learn
data science by informatics
part of the idea is not to get only the
pi to collaborate but have the actual
laboratory with the people on the bench
be able to use
bioinformatics tools liaison with a more
expert person and then utilize the
external resources whether commercial
collaborative or nih resources
that could be doing this because it
would be very difficult for us to hire a
big team of people to handle some of our
projects
all right yes great thank you very much
dr casulis and sona i i know that uh you
as a researcher and uh especially as a
director of a program i know that
students come to your program from all
over the world
uh with all kinds of different
intentions and you know your goal in
just a short time to train them for what
will be expected so i know that you're
probably
feeling out there in the industry and
the research you know what are the
skills that people are looking for in a
bioinformatician or somebody that does
systems medicine uh what do you think
are some of the necessary skills that
you're looking for them to acquire and
and be graduated with to make them ready
for that next position
uh thank you yeah i've actually must
confess that i've lost sleep over this
um
just because it's not right it's not
practical and it's not easy to
create a bioinformatician ideal by
implementation who has lab skill sets um
statistical skill sets and understanding
data and at the end of the day
we are all trying to solve problems
which are biological in nature
and so it's a very challenging things
and i do get students with different
backgrounds i have students who have
psychology backgrounds i in fact had a
student had a history background so it's
a very challenging thing but in the
least what i try to do is give them some
basic foundation of the biology and the
questions that we're trying to address
um and then give them a broad skill sets
of a little bit of statistics um and a
little bit of programming skill sets but
unfortunately not everyone has the
ackman or uh you know the mindset
um to grasp everything
but the program what i try to do is just
to expose them to different aspects of
informatics out there
so they don't come out as
hardcore software engineers
but at the same time they have basic
foundation that they can build on uh to
develop their software skill sets if
that's what they want to pursue um or if
their students want to go and work in
the bench to you know bend sign then
they do have exposure to
understand how to extract rna and how do
you prepare the samples to send for
sequencing and do rna-seq analysis
and they do have an overall um all of
them actually walk out with
with the um you know aspect that we are
all drowned in data so how do you look
at data so statistics is a big part of
it
um and so they do learn
they do learn statistics um so students
after they graduate with skill sets in
different areas then they decide where
they want to develop more
um and so you know some of them
you know take courses and electives to
make some of the foundations more strong
based on their interest but one thing
that is um important in the program is
that
uh they all do research so
capstone project isn't um you know is
mandatory for them so that's where they
kind of tie in together
and become experts in one small thing
some of them are interested in
programming so we find mentors who
you know engage them in learning
programming and some of them want to do
bench work so
so it's all over the place but at the
end of the day they develop a little bit
of wine tasting aspects of different
things
and they then they go ahead and develop
whatever skills that they need um of
course long story short i think i would
if i were to hire someone
um of course i don't have um you know
humongous amount of money to hire a
statistician a biologist and all of
those things so uh with limited funding
we just have to pick a student who has a
little bit of understanding of
programming and biology for sure
and then who embraces um the use of
software tools resources
um and you know understands uh how to
put together data in the context of
biology
all right great thank you for that
perspective too and um dr harris uh you
know the same question i wanted to kind
of rephrase uh for what i know about
what you do i know that many times you
deal with students that have maybe very
limited background in bioinformatics and
nevertheless you're able to integrate
them in some of the excellent projects
that you do
providing them with a meaningful
experience and i know that you also put
out a number of uh resources out there
that you know are facilitating that
process of getting people interested and
so um i wonder what is your take on
you know how to essentially get started
for somebody that wants to get involved
in a meaningful research involving
bioinformatics and how does that
experience prepare them for what real
bioinformatics needs out there uh exists
yeah i was wondering if i was going to
get a question variation simply because
my answer to the first question would be
radically different than the other
panelists um
i'm one because as you said i i don't
get a lot of students that have
expertise i've never hired an intern
i've never hired a graduate student
for research that is i hired them as
teaching assistants and other things
like that
but
for me personally it's more about the
personal characteristics of the student
are they curious
are they curious enough to go find an
answer rather than wait for me to give
it to them
even if they don't know where to look at
least trying gets you somewhere
or if they do run into a problem are
they going to shut down and not ask
questions or are they going to come
forward immediately and start asking
questions of their fellow researchers of
me of whatever people they run into at
conferences or what have you
so a lot of those characteristics are
more along the lines of what i look for
rather than i'm looking for someone in
stats or i'm looking for someone in comp
or i'm looking for someone in bio
because for the students i get which can
be anywhere from basic high school all
the way through graduate level
they don't necessarily know what they
want they don't know what they're
interested in they don't know where
their anxieties are
and so
coming into my research lab or my
trainings frequently that's an
experience they're learning about
themselves and so i get to discover that
alongside them sometimes they get into a
bioinformatics project and they find you
know what the computer really isn't as
exciting as i thought it would be or the
lab is not as exciting as i
thought it would be
and so things like you know flexibility
uh perseverance attention to detail
cannot stress that enough
are all very important things that i
look for rather than looking for a skill
set i can train a skill set i can train
a biologist i can train a computational
scientist but i can't train curiosity i
can't train attention to detail
and that's really where i need the
students to step up and bring those uh
characteristics to the to the plate
okay perfect so
uh thank you again
dr harris for your perspective and for
everybody that shared um
all of this uh wonderful information i
do want to mention that we have
a link and maybe your javascript
you can paste that link where we have
profiles of all of the panelists and
speakers
where you can find links to their
websites to their programs you can learn
about their background and you can
obviously
you know connect with them if you would
like to or they would like to accept
that request but i hope that you know
this not only
provides us with some perspectives but
also leads to other outcomes now i want
to briefly introduce
another person that wants to that can
add an important perspective to this um
so uh geo or gipoliano chavez
uh he is a mentor
at the summer
internship program uh run by you as ucsd
but also um is starting to mentor some
of the students that come to our
research fellowship program and i wanted
uh geo to ask you if you could add a
little bit of your perspective on how
at the very early stages you know how do
you help students uh you know
essentially get interested
and do something meaningful
with
data
and i know that you lead some projects
on your own but also you kind of became
converted to the field of bioinformatics
not so long ago so maybe you could give
us a little perspective from your side
what do you think about
this yeah i was particularly interested
when dr laura harris mentioned that
about the curiosity of students is is
the person
curious
are they curious about
diseases or what what the phenomenons
that have led to a disease in their
family for instance
so
a lot of
countries have problems in
allowing access to
science resources for instance i come
from brazil
i come from public schools in brazil and
uh
you know
there are lots of limitations in the
country there uh
so i came as part of an effort that the
government of the of brazil is is doing
right now or has been doing in the past
uh decade or so
to
launch science or to
try to cultivate a culture of science in
the country
so
we have collaborations we have i have
been as as a latina mentioned i have
been serving as a mentor for a program
called science internship program at the
university of california santa cruz
and the
mission of that program is to really
bring
uh
mainly high school students but
as i turn it to realize it's expanding
from
the only the
scope of high school students should
become uh
to be in contact with scientists with
mentors so what sip the science
internship program does
is it brings uh high school students to
follow to shadow
phd students uh i think that i think
there might be masters students that
also serve as mentors
of sip
and that really uh
makes the student think
i really want to pursue a career in
science or i definitely do not want to
pursue a career in science in science
because that's also
important to
have that decision and having the
resources to
decide on whether or not pursuing a
career in science
so i think it's really important
to
as early as possible start to educate
kids and young scientists
young scientists may be not a very good
term to a good way to put it
because uh we just want to make sure and
guarantee that uh kids have a chance to
understand what science is and have a
feeling of what working in a site in a
in a science lab in a research
institution what it looks like and
i think it's really important uh that in
in countries that do not have a an
economic situation like the united
states or or the the so-called first
world economies i i think it's really
important to allow these other countries
these other
regions these other communities
to
build this type of uh this type of
experience for their uh for their eu for
the their young generations
thank you gio um so
in summary um i just wanted to ask
all of you uh all of the panelists um to
maybe if you want to add anything to
what we discussed in this panel we do
have a few questions from the audience
that i will read out in just a couple of
minutes but before we do that i wanted
to give you an opportunity to just maybe
say a couple more things from your
perspective again the the topic of the
panel is the changing
kind of need
of bioinformatics and the changing
kind of technologies in this field we
will continue to hear about it in more
in-depth talks in just a few minutes um
but
please does anybody want to
anybody from the panel want to add
something to this topic from what we
discussed so far um dr andina would you
like to add anything to this
this this has been a you know tremendous
uh exciting uh discussion i think we all
in the panel
recognize the importance of um bringing
uh
knowledge saying young people everybody
i would say newcomers uh to these
activities i think that uh will be uh
incredibly important if you know really
this symposium brings uh people together
to uh realize um the power and also the
challenges and this exercise i mean i
guess the only thing that i i wanted to
to say is um you know just emphasize
that um it really is a is a human
activity is bringing together by
statisticians
with um you know empirical scientists if
you will and together to these
discussions um the curiosity point is
very well taken uh i think it
you know we all need to um emphasize
that you know that is something that is
essential uh to the um to the process um
and i i like this idea that you create
this circle interactive circle uh
between you know data analyst and
experimentalist because you know if you
think about it you can you can have a
big data set and discover something that
is
um inspiring in terms of creating a new
model a new perspective of how you see
something
but you at some point you need to
validate that
observation and how do you confirm that
observation is real well you need an
experiment
so i i think again this is a team effort
and is um you know and i my personal
experience uh working with leonid uh
broski and elia broski and this all
these last 10 years or so that we've
been working together
has been that i learned a lot
um myself educate myself by these
interactions and i think that's a very
exciting from my
perspective the possibility of continue
learning
um and not being so young but a newcomer
all right thank you dr and you know
that's a great perspective there and uh
dr lena bronski would you like to add
anything
okay
[Music]
by bioinformatics is is becoming very
complex
actually the entire science
from
mathematics to quantum computers
uh
is involved in bioinformatics
and also bio biology itself is is
developing very fast
so
a lot of challenges and actually all
challenges
should be covered by education
and
actually the education has to be
a little bit
in front of challenges say
and
i believe that education is very
substantial part of
bioinformatics in general
and by not only bioinformatics but this
this
joint venture of bioinformatics and
biology
because without biology bioinformatics
it's nothing
great thank you uh thank you for the
perspective and uh
dr casulis would you like to add any uh
final words to this discussion yeah uh
obviously uh i think we're all in
agreement of the importance of these
fields and the challenges that we face
but uh you know in a simple way
you know advanced data science
bioinformatics really can find in middle
in the haystack but uh
the way that we're even indicated
ultimately you have to really look
whether that needle is actually doing
something so it's a unification of
really
the data science mathematics and
ultimately experimentation that will
give you uh you know the the answers uh
to what you may need so we need both and
i can tell you because i've served as
associate vice president for louisiana
university almost seven years and ended
up reviewing a lot of engineering and
physics projects astrophysics fluid
dynamics mechanical engineering and i
tell you there's a lot of
solutions developed by other fields that
have not yet really fully applied
in biology so i think this merging of
disciplines uh is required and we need
to educate the new generation students
most medical schools and most veterinary
schools
have practically very little of
education towards this
you know mds and dvms for genetics
genomics and the use of this tool so we
need a
transformative steps in
higher education
to be able to really
train the new
scientists that will be able to use
these tools
because these tools cannot be only at
the hands of experts extremely that dr
brodsky mentioned to really educate
people
all right great thank you very much dr
vasudevan any final words
um yes i agree with all the panelists
and i think education is the most
important thing it's not just educating
students but also educating
faculty who are in different fields and
who are still scared to come and use
data and understand so i feel like the
educate the education should spread to a
lot of faculty as well
in an institution in addition to
students
because i have several faculty on my own
um you know my own colleagues
who are either scared or who don't are
skeptical just because there's no
knowledge of how to use data they all
have lots of data and now um
i think everyone will agree that this is
a new language and i think this language
has to be learned by everyone
and um and i think as to as dr kasil has
just said we need transformative
educational programs and i think ilya
pine biotech is actually leading in that
i really like how we are putting
together
and i also agree with dr chavez that the
education should start at the high
school level
sometimes what i teach my graduate
students i do teach high school students
i mentor high school students and it's
amazing to find that sometimes they're
smarter
come up with better ideas than graduate
students
so i think that there is lots of thirst
right there and all the school systems
have to integrate informatics
starting from high school undergraduate
medical school of course i'm trying my
best at georgetown as well so
um i think this is a very important
language that everyone should learn at
whatever career paths that they actually
take
things have changed
excellent thank you
dr harris what would you like to add
well i echo
the other panelists have said about how
the students
the graduate students the post docs and
even the faculty need to be trained in
interdisciplinary research and that is a
challenge particularly for us old farts
who are stuck in our ways
with that said it is a challenge for
students coming up because it seems like
they need or feel the need to pick a
topic and i really just want to
encourage people to follow their
interests follow their curiosity follow
what drives them because you never know
where that's going to lead you and one
day that could be something that's
specifically biology another day that
could be something that's more
computational and then a year later you
begin to realize how they integrate
together
so just don't let yourself
limit your potential
and just keep your head up and moving
forward and as fast of a positive
direction as you can
thank you dr harris uh indeed very
inspirational to continue
and uh finally uh
geo uh dr chavez would you like to just
uh add a couple more words to this just
from your perspective uh one second let
me in
there we go
yeah uh i agree that uh
science is an activity is a human
activity that we as humans we should all
be engaged in i just i just think that
um
the
it's a personal uh not a personal it's
it's an effort i guess that all of the
countries and all of the societies
need to do
uh in engaging their uh their
populations in this activity that can uh
bring benefits for the for the societies
in general
all right great thank you geo and thank
you all the panelists i want to mention
again to everyone that we have profiles
of all of the speakers
right here you can find all of the
speakers and panelists with their
background
you will find if you click on these
images you will actually get links